c-130 missie Pistorius you may be seated
until I ask you to rise
on 11 September 2014 this court
convicted the accused of inter alia
culpable homicide and sentenced him to
imprisonment for a period of not
exceeding five years in terms of section
276 one eye of the Criminal Procedure
Act 51 of 1977 subsequently this court
acting in terms of the Criminal
Procedure Act section three one nine and
on application by the state reserved
three questions of law for the
consideration of the Supreme Court of
Appeal having had counts of the Supreme
Court of Appeal made the following
finding I quote
of Public Prosecutions to the accused
conviction and sentence on count one are
set aside
in the form of Dulles eventually closing
her coat three the meta is referred back
to the trial court to consider an
appropriate sentence afresh in the light
of the comments in this judgment close
homes in brackets see the Director of
Public Prosecutions
Housing this is crystal Pistorius two
zero one six one one as a CR 4 3 1 in
brackets SC a close brackets paragraph
52 it now remains for this court to
impose an appropriate sentence to
determine a fitting punishment based on
fairness and proportion I have to
consider several factors namely the
offender the offense and the interests
of society as well as the victims of the
offense
I am also obliged to have regard to the
main purposes of punishment which are a
retribution deterrence prevention and
rehabilitation lastly because of the
nature of the offense that the accused
has been found guilty or I have to
determine whether there exists
substantial and compelling circumstances
justifying the imposition of a lesser
sentence than 15 years imprisonment
which is the prescribed minimum sentence
in this case
the evidence both the accused and the
state led the evidence of various
witnesses in mitigation and in
aggravation of sentence for purposes of
this sentencing exercise it is not
necessary to set out in detail every
piece of evidence that was led I have
confined myself to what I consider
strictly necessary although I've had
regard to all the evidence as well as
submissions placed before this court the
only evidence that shall be set out in
detail is that of professor's scores
only because of its nature is expect
evidence and in the detailed report he
compiled such evidence shall be
summarized under this heading only
briefly and be set out in detail under
the personal circumstances of the
accused the evidence of the various
witnesses shall be discussed under
relevant headings here under the first
and main witness for the defense was
Professor scores a clinical psychologist
who assessed the accused and compiled a
pre-sentencing report marked exhibit as
a he had initially featured in this
matter is one of the panelists appointed
to assess the accused during the trial
in 2014 in terms of sections 78 and 79
of the Criminal Procedure Act
professor skulls explained that in view
of his previous involvement in the
matter he had sought and obtained
confirmation from the health professor
Professions Council of South Africa in
brackets brackets h p CS a to proceed
with the assessment
the purposes of centuries in his
assessment of the accused professor
skulls found into earlier that the
accused displayed signs and reported
symptoms of post-traumatic stress
disorder and that he disorder and
depressive disorder his shot to meet
midterm memory was compromised in his
opinion the accused condition was so
severe that he would not be able to
testify in the proceedings he also
informed an opinion that he he should
have been hospitalized as his condition
had worsened since the last time he had
seen him in 2014 I shall say more about
this when I deal with the personal
circumstances of the accused the next
witness was ever good knee good Monto
mundo tear from Iceland she got to know
about the accused a little more than 11
years ago when she was about 20 20 weeks
pregnant and a doctor's informed her
that her son would be born without legs
she and her family were anxious as no
one in Ireland had been born without
legs before she had seen an article
about the accused and his photograph
taken while he was running in Athens
her mother had written to the person who
had interviewed the accused to thank him
for being visible soon thereafter and
quite unexpectedly the accused had
written back to her mother to say that
it would be a pleasure for him to help
in whatever way he could since then he
has visited the family often and cares
for his son as well as for his sister
the third witness was mr. Marius nel
they accused pasta 3c ministries based
in Centurion his evidence was short and
to the point the accused is a member of
his ministry while the accused was
incarcerated mr. nel often paid in a
visit to pray with him minister to him
and to encourage him he found him a
broken man his ministry was involved in
a number of projects meant to assist
disadvantaged children in various
schools
he had discussed with the accused the
possibility of his involvement in sports
and athletics training in some of these
schools and the accused had shown an
interest and was keen to assist and now
deal with the personal circumstances of
the accused I was a short by council
that the personal circumstances of the
accused as we appear on the trial record
had not changed much additional
information was obtained from Professor
scholars report exhibit as a the accused
is 29 years old single and has no
children he is a renowned a renowned
athlete he has no previous convictions
the middle of three children he was born
with a congenital abnormality and at the
age of 11 months he had a bilateral
below the knee amputation he uses
prosthetic legs he attended both primary
and high school in Pretoria when he was
in grade 9 his mother passed on
according to Professor skulls they
accused felt the loss deeply as he had
he and his mother had a very close bond
while he had an also good relationship
with his father
after grade 12 the accused enrolled at
the University of Pretoria for a
Bachelor of Commerce degree in business
economics but had to drop out because of
the demands of his career as an athlete
the background of the accused and his
family is set out in paragraph 2.2 of
exhibit essay in part it reads as
follows I quote history and development
of mr. Pistorius family constellation
and relationships mother even though
there was never any violence of serious
aggression between his mother and father
the couple divorced when mr. Pistorius
was six years old mr. Pistorius mother
did her best after the divorce and
remained positive and strong even though
her family had to adapt in difficult
circumstances especially financially she
motivated Pistorius to live his life as
normal as possible in spite of the
problems he experienced as a double
amputee she was however also an anxious
person and gods startled easily she
acquired a pistol when she met her
husband and learned to shoot after the
divorce she would become scared and
anxious at times when she felt they were
under threat unfortunately there were a
few incidents of crime that the family
experienced directly or indirectly as
and this exhibit exacerbated her anxiety
these experiences left a lasting
impression on the young Mississippi
stories making him aware of his families
and his own vulnerability to crime and
increasing his fear of being a victim of
crime
scope professor schools states that the
sudden passing of his mother when he was
15 years old left the accused feeling
traumatized and abandoned
he states that they accuse relationship
with his father after the divorce was
poor but he subsequently found father
figures mainly his uncle Arnold he had a
close or he has a close relationship
with both his elder brother and his
younger sister his sister left the
country recently this also was felt by
the accused as a loss the accused was
incarcerated for 12 months at ocimum
guru Ho C Mon Peru Correctional Center
after his release he was placed under
house arrest at the residence of his
uncle and aunt during his incarceration
the accused completed a number of
courses in workshops as part of his
rehabilitation program according to
Professor sports they accused views
about possession and use of firearms has
changed he sold all his firearms and
never wants to touch a firearm again he
is not antisocial or psychopathic
psychopathic he is currently enrolled
for a BSc degree at University of London
professor skulls views are that the
accused mental health has deteriorated
since 2014
he states and I quote since their
friends he has developed a serious
psychiatry condition which has got worse
over the past two years major depression
and post-traumatic stress disorders his
level of anxiety have in brackets
si si close brackets also increased
he has become isolated and fearful of
venturing out in public clothes coat
professor skulls is also of the opinion
that the accused current condition I
quote
warrants hospital hospitalization
clothes coat he also states that because
of the accused international profile he
has had that is the accused has had to
endure intense media attention and
negative reports about him you also had
to enjoy a constant pressure and
harassment from the media in his report
professor skulls also deals with what he
refers to as traumatic and humiliating
experiences that they accused allegedly
had during his incarceration these
however were unsupported by anything
concrete
most of these experiences were denied or
put in perspective by mrs. M Sima
Shibani
the Assistant Health Manager at the
Xhosa mamuro prison mrs. márcia Bonney
explained that the accused could not
have overhead the rape of a young man
force in the body after the young man
had hanged himself as the accused had
alleged as as the section where the
incident happened was far from where the
accused was accommodated miss ma Shivani
appeared to me an honest witness and I
was given no reason to reject her
evidence and I accepted as true and
reliable on the other hand this Court
Accords very little weight to most of
what the accused hold professor schools
for the following reasons there was no
way to test the veracity of the
complaints as the accused did not give
evidence secondly professor skulls did
not fare well under cross-examination
when us details about the infection
allegedly
suffered by the accused because he had
no seat or chair in his shower for the
first five weeks he could provide none
in addition the allegation that the
accused health had deteriorated was
irreconcilable with what was put to
state witnesses that they accused was
hoarding medication which he had legally
obtained over time from the nurses the
second senses stroke a gravity of the
crime
meda is always a very serious crime the
fact that the actions thought it was an
intruder does not make it less serious
serious is the crime is for purposes of
sentencing it is always useful to place
facts that led to the particular murder
in perspective a short background of
circumstances in which the crime was
committed is therefore important in the
early hours of 14 February 2013 the
accused shot and killed his girlfriend
reeva foreman
Reid reeva Steenkamp they deceased in
his home in Pretoria at the trial the
accused explained that he had mistakenly
shot and killed the deceased through the
locked toilet door in his bathroom as he
had thought then that there was an
intruder who had entered the house
through the bathroom window and who
posed a threat to him and the deceased
at the time of the shooting he was on
his stumps when he discovered his
mistake he put on his prosthetic legs
and using the cricket back to bash open
the door he was able to unlock it and
reach the deceased the accused pecan
picked her up and took her downstairs
hope
to get her to hospital minutes later
still a the accused house the deceased
was declared dead by paramedics
witnesses who saw the action soon after
the incident told this court that the
accused looked distraught dr. Stephen
neighbor and state witness with earlier
head what he had referred to as shots
and screams had no doubt that the
accused stress was genuine there was
also evidence that the accused was
crying and calling upon God to intervene
notwithstanding the above circumstances
it is worth repeating that the murder is
a serious offense in the present case a
deadly weapon in the form of a firearm
was used in the results were devastating
the fact that the meta to place and the
circumstances as described above does
not in any way make the offense any less
serious I now deal with the interest of
society the interests of society demand
that people who commit serious crimes
such as murder be punished severely the
interests of society that are considered
and protected however must be legitimate
interest counsel for defense for the
defense correctly submitted that there
was an unfortunate perception in the
minds of some people that on the night
of the murder there was an argument
between the accused and the deceased and
that this is what led to the murder of
the deceased the existence of such a
perception was inadvertently confirmed
by the father of the deceased
there is Stinkum who during the course
of his evidence let slip this very
perception that counts for the state
stopped mrs. teen come from proceeding
any further
does not change the fact that such a
perception does exist it therefore
cannot be ignored by this court the
unfortunate part of it is that there is
no not a shred of evidence placed before
this court that supports such a
perception courts deal with facts plays
before them not with assumptions and not
with suspicions the fact that an accused
may not have taken a court into his
confidence or that he lied in certain
respects does not give such court the
right to speculate against the accused
and to act on such speculations I might
also add that although this case
attracted the attention of groups
fighting for men's rights there is no
indication at all and that the deceased
was in an abusive relationship there is
also no evidence whatsoever that this
case is best based on gender violence
had there been such evidence it would
certainly have been a definite
aggravating factor
I shall return to this issue of the
misperceptions from the public in my
judgment when I deal with the
submissions by counsel on the
appropriate sentence
society at large has a real interest in
the present methods mainly because both
the accused and the deceased were
well-known personalities with
illustrious careers they were celebrated
both here at home and abroad it is
therefore not surprising that there
would be an unprecedented level of
interest in the proceedings and in the
outcome and that the incident the trial
and the possible outcome would beat
would become talking points for some
time society has a right to have certain
expectations and to demand justice
however such expectations must be legit
legitimate expectations before the court
can take heed of them it follows that
expectations cannot be legitimate if
they are based on wrong perceptions I
deal with the deceased
and her family although the deceased
belong to a family which is part of the
wider community it is necessary to deal
with the deceased and a family
separating the deceased was young
reversions full of life and hope for the
future this picture was painted by the
deceased father mr. Baris Telkom and the
deceased cousin Kim Michelle Martin both
told of the pain that the family has
suffered and continues to suffer as a
result of the deceased untimely death
miss Martin described the deceased as a
loving and wonderful person she stated
that as a family they would never
completely get over the death of the
deceased the deceased had plans not only
for herself but for her parents as well
she supported her parents financially
and expressed the wish to continue to do
so to make their lives
easy according to NASA Steenkamp the
deceased used to call home almost every
weekend to talk to him and his wife
separately it is therefore not
surprising that three years later the
family is still grieving it is clear
from the evidence that the Starck
stinkums had a very close bond and used
to celebrate special occasions together
as a family now Christmas birthdays and
Valentine's Day I pay for reminder that
the deceased is no longer with them it
is on such days that they feel the loss
deeply mrs. tan comes spoke of the
impact the deceased death has had on him
specifically he now suffers from ill
health he thinks of the deceased every
day he has her photographs every way in
the house he now avoids meeting people
and often gets up at 3 o'clock in the
morning to sit in the veranda smoking
and talking to the deceased he told his
court that his wife also suffers as much
as he does the evidence of both mrs.
Steenkamp and Miss Martin shows that the
pain runs deep and that the impact of
the accused conduct on the family of the
deceased has been devastating miss
Martin told the Scot that the family is
anxious and depressed they have been
exposed to the media
she is loathe to meet people or go
places as she never knows when someone
might say something about the deceased
they accused or about the incident she
however has to cope and go on with her
life for the sake of his children and
that fact is relevant and must be taken
into consideration
in the sentencing process the criminal
law Amendment Act 105 of 1997 in
brackets at 105 of 1997 in terms of the
provisions of at 105 of 1997 as amended
this Court is obliged to impose the
prescribed minimum sentence which is 15
years imprisonment unless of course
there exists substantial and compelling
circumstances justifying the imposition
of a lesser sentence than the prescribed
minimum sentence section 51 two a of the
Act that is act 105 of 1997 specifically
provides that when an accused who is a
first offender is convicted of murder
that is not planned or premeditated the
court shall sentence him or her to
imprisonment for a period of not less
than 15 months the Act does not define
the phrase I quote substantial and
compelling circumstances close combs but
is left to the courts to make that
determination
fortunately the correct approach in this
regard is set out in s mrs. Marquez 2001
volume 1 little as ACR 469 close bracket
FCA
I have to rephrase this fortunately the
correct approach in this regard is set
out in a Swiss Malgus 2001 Volume one
sacr 469 in brackets SCA they're the
Supreme Court of Appeals stated the
following in short I count in short the
legislature aimed at assuring a severe
standardized and consistent response
from the courts to the commission of
such crimes unless the way and could be
seen to be truly convincing reasons for
a different response when considering
sentence the emphasis was to be shifted
to the objective gravity of the type of
crime and the public's need for
effective sanctions against it but that
did not mean that all other
considerations were to be ignored the
residual discretion to decline to pass
the sentence which the commission of
such an offence would ordinarily attract
plainly was given to the courts in
recognition of the easily foreseeable in
justices which could result from
obliging them to pass the specific
sentences come what may close quote
in s visas Villa Ghazi 2012 volume 6 as
ACR 353 SCA in brackets at paragraph 15
the following was said I caught 15 it is
clear from the terms in which the test
was framed in Marquez an endorsed in
dodo that it is incumbent upon a court
in every case before it imposes a
prescribed sentence to assess upon a
consideration of all the circumstances
of the particular case whether the
prescribed sentence is indeed
proportionate to the particular offense
their constitutional kata Medicare that
what it meant by the offence in that
context I leave out something consist of
all factors relevant to the nature and
seriousness of the criminal act itself
as well as all the relevant personnel in
other circumstances relating to the
offender which could have a bearing on
the seriousness of the offense and the
culpability of the offender if a court
is indeed satisfied satisfied that a
lesser sentence is called for in a
particular case thus justifying the
departure from the prescribed sentence
then it hardly needs saying that the
court is bound to impose that lesser
sentence that was also made here in
Marquez which said that the relevant
provision in the act vests the
sentencing court with power indeed the
obligation to consider whether the
particular circumstances of the case
require a different sentence to be
imposed and a different sentence must be
imposed if the court is satisfied that
substantial
and compelling circumstances exist which
justified I live out something it's
close colt malukas in paragraph 22 puts
it this way the more Akkad feels and
easy about an imposition of a prescribed
sentence the greater its anxiety will be
that it may be perpetrating and
injustice and once that injustice that
once that an easiness becomes a
convention a conviction then an
injustice will be done in my view their
barb is a reminder that each case ought
still to be decided on its own peculiar
effects a useful point of departure
therefore is a proper investigation of
the pertinent facts and circumstances in
the present matter in addition to answer
the question whether there exists
substantial and compelling circumstances
justifying a lesser sentence courts must
also consider aggravating factors as
well as mitigate made mitigation factors
mitigating factors in a particular
matter
I deal with aggravating factors and
mitigating factors in the present case
there a number of aggravating factors
the accused used a little a little
little weapon a high caliber firearm in
annually ammunition and fired not one
but four shots into the toilet door
knowing full well that there was someone
behind the door the toilet was a small
cubicle and there was no room for escape
for the person behind the door the
accused had been trained in the use of
and in handling firearms he used the
firearm without taking precaution of
firing a warning
as found by the Supreme Court of Appeal
mitigating factors are the following the
accuse approached the bathroom in the
belief that an intruder had entered his
house at the time he was without his
prosthesis for prosthesis and felt
vulnerable his belief that there was an
intruder in the house is supported by
his actions when he realized that it was
the deceased in the toilet
details of the sequence of events after
the shooting most of which were not
disputed are on record it is not
necessary to repeat them for purposes of
sentencing suffice is to state that the
accused
immediately took steps to try to save
their deceased life doctor stick
believed in belief in the same complex
gave evidence that when he went to the
accused house soon after the shooting
the accused implored him to do something
to save the deceased life he was
distraught and kept on asking God to
save the deceased life and promising to
save him in return
what is significant about this evidence
is that it was volunteered by a state
witness and that no other evidence was
led to contradict it counsel for the
state submitted that the way no
substantial and compelling circumstances
justifying a lesser sentence than the
prescribed minimum sentence he
reiterated that the accused showed no
remorse as he did not come clean before
this Court
I disagree and the commencement of the
proceedings
the accused apologized to the family of
the deceased this public apology could
easily
have been interpreted as a ploy to gain
public sympathy had it not been for the
fact that the accused had previously and
unsuccessfully tried to meet the parents
of the deceased to apologise for the
pain that he had caused them and to us
for forgiveness what weighs heavy with
me amongst other things is that the
request was repeated more than once this
court was informed that after his
release from incarceration the accused
tried once more to approach the deceased
family with an apology without success
Mrs T on cam confirmed that the accused
had made such a request through his
lawyers but the Steenkamp family was not
yet ready to meet the accused it is my
view that it must be one of the most
difficult things for any accused to have
to face the victims of his crime and to
apologize it is highly improbable
therefore that the accused would persist
in his request to meet the parents of
the deceased and ask for forgiveness if
he was not genuinely remorseful counsel
for the state submitted further that in
the event the court found that the
substantial and compelling circumstances
exist justifying a lesser sentence than
the prescribed minimum sentence the
court still ought to impose a very long
term of imprisonment on the basis that
the crime the accused was found guilty
of bordered on Dolly's directors I
disagree with this submission there is
no suggestion in the judgment of the
Supreme Court of Appeal that this is the
case
the finding of the Supreme Court of
Appeal was that the accused had intent
in the form of dollars eventually it is
this finding that this Court has to bear
in mind and use as a basis to impose a
sentence of fresh I have taken all the
above into consideration and I'm of the
view that mitigating circumstances
outweigh the aggravating factors I find
that they are substantial and compelling
circumstances which justify a deviation
from the imposition of the prescribed
minimum sentence of 15 years the
appropriate sentence while it is true
that sentences ought to be standardized
or consistent each case is different and
sentences must be in defeat
individualized this Court is indebted
indebted to both counsel who referred to
a number of cases during their
submissions although none of the cases
can be said to be on all fours with a
present case they certainly assisted as
a guide as a starting point counsel for
the defense zeroed in on concerns that
he submitted had a potential to cloud
the real issues the first had to do with
an impression gained by the public that
the accused was found guilty of dollars
directors when in fact he was found
guilty of dollars
Evangelos the second had to do with the
fact that the accused was in the minds
of most most people protract portrayed
as the confidence one point eight four
meters tall strong ambitious person
winning gold medals this obscured the
relevant fact that at the time the
accused shot at the toilet door and
killed the deceased it was 3 o'clock in
the morning and dark he was not wearing
his prosthesis but was on his stamps and
measured 1.5 meters in height and felt
vulnerable the third had to do with
emotions of the public emanating from
the perceptions above defense counsel
submitted that because of these emotions
there was a danger that the effect true
facts might escape the general public
who may then have unreasonable
expectations in terms of an outcome I
shall come back to these submissions
later Council for the state sought to
argue that mrs. Ian comes pain had
nothing to do with any perception he
might have heard about what led to the
death of the deceased and that in fact
to link the two would be to diminish a
father's real pain I do not think that
any way anything anyone says or does can
diminish the pain suffered by the
deceased family the pain is there it is
real and it is tangible nevertheless the
misfits misperception that there was an
argument before the deceased was shot
and killed and that the accused was
guilty of murder
flawless the directors
cannot be ignored as to do so may not
serve the ends of justice I returned to
submission by counsel for the accused
concerning the public's perception of
what may have happened on the 14th
February 2013 that the submissions by
defense counsel have married in so far
as some members of the public is
concerned cannot be disputed and
therefore constrained to accept that all
these submissions which were made were
made with good reason
had it not been for the unique features
of this case and the wide publicity the
case has attracted I would probably have
dismissed such submissions as improper
and unnecessary I say this for the
following reasons our courts are courts
of law not cause of public opinion while
judicial officers I expected to and
should adjudicate matters without fear
without favor and without prejudice the
court is aware that natural indignation
of interested persons and of the
community at large should and does
receive some recognition in the
sentences that cuts imposed as counsel
for the state correctly argued in
bracket C our visas hogs felt K Arg 1961
vol 1 s a 2 3 1 capital a in brackets at
2 3 6 close the brackets however in my
view such indignation must be based on
facts as reflected in the evidence
properly placed before court under oath
and tested and a cross-examination
we're a wrong perception about a
particular effect exist as it does in
this matter and has been brought to the
attention of the court it is the duty of
the court to correct it and put the
correct facts in perspective to prevent
unjustified outrage from the public it
is appropriate at this stage to say
something about the limited role of
public opinion in sentencing as set out
in s visa since a casa in another 1997
one sacr v one v SCA in brackets their
harems j a stated into a Lea that the
object of sentencing was not to satisfy
satisfy public opinion but to serve or
lead public opinion or the public
interest
he stated that a sentencing policy that
catered predominantly or exclusively for
public opinion was inherently flawed as
it was the cost duty to impose an
appropriate and fair sentence fearlessly
even if the sentence did not satisfy the
public he further stated the following I
quote public opinion may have some
relevance to the inquiry but in itself
it is no substitute for the duty vested
in the court the court cannot allow
itself to be diverted from its duty to
act as an independent arbiter by making
choices on the basis that they will find
favor with the public close codes in the
present case public opinion may be loud
and persistent but it can play no role
in the decision of this Court
the objective facts on the merits in
this matter our own record and do not
warrant repetition for purposes of the
present procedure suffice it to state
that as defense counsel correctly
submitted those facts have not been
disturbed as no further evidence was led
on appeal it is those facts not
conjecture and certainly not
suppositions which will guide this court
in its decision defense counsel is
correct in his submission that this
court ought not to lose sight of the
fact that there Oscar in Coates was shot
and killed the deceased on the morning
of 14 February 2013 was not the
acclaimed Oscar in coasts who defied
odds on the racetrack and worn medals my
view is that even without the physical
demonstration that took place in court
to show the difference between the
accused on stamps and they accused on
his prosthetic prosthetic legs it is
easy to see that we are here dealing
with two different persons this was
clearly set out by Professor skulls in
his earlier report exhibit QQ
this evidence
this evidence was not contradicted and
the assessment of the accused
personality in this manner is not
far-fetched in my view to ignore this
fact would be truly an injustice in my
view however it is also important to
keep in mind that the accused is just
one of the many considerations in the
sentencing process there are others
equally important and they also have to
be taken in I understood counsel for the
defense to be contending in brackets as
though not in so many ways close
brackets for a noncustodial sentence
relying on the report of Professor
skulls he submitted inter alia that a
custodial sentence would serve no
purpose as the accused had been
rehabilitated he based his submissions
on the fact that the accused had
completed a number of causes causes and
had attended workshops while he was
incarcerated this submission was a sight
of the fact that rehabilitation is only
one of the purposes of punishment the
other purposes namely retribution
deterrence reformation and prevention
are just as important and ought to be
properly addressed as well they'd agree
with with which each fish will feature
in any sentence and procedure will
depend on the crime the accused has been
found guilty of as well as on the
circumstances of each case circumstances
in this matter have changed as the
accused has now been found guilty of
murder dollars Evangelos which is a more
serious offense than culpable homicide
having regard to the changed
circumstances the rehabilitation
programs that the accused was exposed to
during his incarceration may or may not
be sufficient for present purposes that
is now that the accused has been found
guilty of a more serious crime it is not
for this court to determine their
sufficiency or insufficiency that is the
prerogative of the prison authorities if
they're accused is sent to prison this
court however is obliged to and does
take into consideration the fact that
the accused
successfully completed completed the
programs referred to above this in my
view is an indication that the accused
is a good candidate for rehabilitation
and that the other purposes of
punishment though important or to not to
play a dominant role in the sentencing
process also to be tape to be taken into
consideration is the fact that the
accused has already spent some time in
in cancer it in prison serving his
original sentence I may add that a
contrary impression to whether the
accused was a good candidate for the
rehabilitation may have been created
perhaps inadvertently during the
cross-examination of Professor skulls
when it was put to him that initially
the accused had difficulty adjusting as
an inmate professor Scott was quick to
disagree with such a statement stating
that the accused was not a violent
person the basis of the disagreement was
not clear to me as no one has said
anything about the accused
violent by nation what was said was
simply effect as observed by the author
of the reports that initially the
accused struggled to adjust as an inmate
incited relevant examples of an
acceptable conduct I did not get the
impression from this report or from
anything stated by anyone during the
proceedings that prison authorities were
trying to vilify the accused or brand
him as a violent person on the contrary
from the documentation place before this
court and the evidence the impression I
got was that after the initial
challenges that they accused head to
adjust he had made progress and was
cooperative cooperating with prison
authorities the fact is that they accuse
may peps be quick-tempered does not
necessarily mean he's a violent person
defense also sought to rely on Professor
skulls evidence that the accused needed
to be hospitalized as his condition had
worsened since the last time he saw him
in 2014 I am in agreement with counsel
for the state that professors calls
evidence in this regard is not
convincing I say this for the following
reasons one there was no confirmation
from the accused treating psychiatrist
that the accused condition was such that
his admission to hospital was warranted
to no steps were taken to have the
accused admitted to hospital
notwithstanding that according to
Professor skulls he had discussed the
issue with the accuse psychiatrist dr.
Bosch the inference is irresistible that
dr. Bosch does not support professor
skulls view
on the meta conclusion the determination
of an appropriate sentence that
satisfies every relevant interest is
never easy it is made even more
difficult by the fact that nothing is
that this Court will do or say today
shall bring back the life of the
deceased as stated earlier each case
must be assessed on its own facts in
search of a balance between the accused
personal circumstances the gravity of
the offense the interest of society as
well as the victim of the offense
committed all these have been taken into
account earlier I sat out the impact of
there to be a crime committed by that
shoeses head on the family of the
deceased it is difficult to fully
describe its ramification what was
evident from the testimony of both mr.
Steenkamp and Miss Martin is that their
lives shall never be the same details of
what they went through and are still
going through as a family have been
described about thankfully healing has
already started is both mrs. Jenkins and
mrs. Jenkins have stated that they have
forgiven they accused the life of the
accused shall also never be the same
he is a fallen hero who has lost his
career and is reined financially the
worst is that having taken the life of a
fellow human being in the manner that he
did he cannot be at peace it came as no
surprise therefore when both mr. Nell
his pasta and professor skulls described
him as a broken man recovery is possible
but it will depend mostly on the accused
attitude to the punishment imposed on
him this Court is aware that they
accused through his posture has shown a
willingness and expressed a wish to do
community work as punishment that is a
noble gesture
however punishment is not what you
choose to do it is something that is
imposed on you by its very nature
punishment is unpleasant it is
uncomfortable it is painful and it's
inconvenient it is certainly not what
you love to do I have considered the
evidence in this matter their
submissions and argument by counsel as
well as the relevant case law and other
authorities although a custodial
sentence is the proper sentence I am of
the view that a long term of
imprisonment will not serve justice in
this matter the accused has already
served a sentence of 12 months
imprisonment he is a first offender and
considering the facts of this matter he
is not likely to reoffend the sentence
that I impose will have to reflect not
only that fact but also the seriousness
of the offence
it will insofar as it is possible have
to be fair to the accused as well as to
the deceased family and society at large
mr. Pistorius please rise
in the result the sentence that I impose
on the accused for the murder dollars
eventual is of the deceased that is
reeva Steenkamp is six years
imprisonment once might like to thank
counsel or counsel involved for the
assistance I'd like to thank all the
officers of this court and all the staff
of this court in the meantime I will
adjourn and I'll be in chambers just in
case I have to come back to court
counsel might like to consider whether
or not they want to apply for leave to
appeal I am willing to hear it today if
that is what comes in one cot village a
I'm on the flow opened in my office I
know for sure
yeah